we were talking the other day about
using different food delivery services
by using breathe which is the right
answer which is not right mainstream
answer and then Joyce what do you use oh
my gosh it's like what I didn't even
know obviously I think I'm right and the
only way to prove it is to test this
challenge you're right yeah all right
let's test this challenge party so
criteria one price range so the livery
price is gonna be different on
everything it's we're all gonna get the
exact same thing all right and the
second criteria how fast does it get
here but at the end of the day you want
your food as fast as possible yes
honestly probably the most important
part yeah truly I think that is
criterion three how great is the
delivery itself do they come to the door
do they call they go me above and beyond
fourth criteria is gonna be the quality
of the order to be honest this one's a
little variable because this could just
be to the restaurants that's you there's
an acid or there's a little asterisk
exit this is a little we're just gonna
test the waters but down on the count of
three everyone say what they're thinking
in their phobic they want to eat okay
one two it's already been a tough Friday
I'm tired
shake shake isn't on over near mine I
smell shake shake it's still not here
why Wow
two pointed gifts wait what about five
guys that guys are great burgers I think
we should get a bacon cheeseburger okay
okay
bacon cheeseburger should we do ketchup
yeah okay and lettuce lettuce pickle
tomato
okay okay okay wait this is one
initiates taniyama so I have to like sit
down but light oh I will say ubereats
for all the other faults this is very
easy it's simple
yeah I'm just clicking the body to
scroll down and click I only has coke
diet coke or sprite
I only has T simply lemonade to sign
here bottle so it didn't even give me an
option for trying wait you have an
option oh you mean I'm sure I just can't
pick what drink so alright so I'm just
gonna get a regular big coke I'm just
gonna add soda country what happened
okay now if the totals with a drink a
bacon cheeseburger and fries yes my uber
eats is $24 and 23 cents my post mate is
$19 and 62 cents $24 is the cheapest
option ready 3 2 1
I mean we're easy ta is 12:15 p.m.
oh my approach is called 2019 and that
always changes we're gonna be down to
the wire mind change to 1208 so soon I'm
James 2:19 oh why why I just think
burned my post me so if you burn my
ubereats and that should love for me
12:04 that's like 10 minutes from
nothing
14 minutes from now this is actually
kind of cute you cannot tell from this
itty bitty bubble mine got bumped up to
8 16 and he said I don't have a
delivery yet I have a person my door -
called me and asked what drink I would
like since it wasn't an optional she
that's but but the website issue - mine
is coming so I just got my guy his name
is Fabio I have a 90 minute ETA damn I
am coming in five minutes
I look he's moving oh my God look he's
great on the way wait mother's in close
oh he's getting away oh my god Oh yours
is trailing so behind I hate going away
from my husband even moves this whole
time so you know door - she really
losing today good salami two minutes ago
so I know she's at the place I just
don't know where she is
right oh my god you're really gonna have
to go outside they just added a minute
to my ETA mmm well I've never tracked
that's so closely now that's a lot I
track it so close oh well I'm hungry I'm
always like why are you why are you got
here and when I see them clothes I like
that on my conscience no pains George
walked away so there's no telling where
her food James why are you facing that
direct she's like oh he's like I forgot
surprise I have to run back to the store
a magic would be epic he's back on it
all right
yeah here alright alright let's look
let's get this going okay you know he's
my guys he's going to the street your
guys on it I said
that is I think the fam that's him Wow
did it hey yeah you guys happy Friday I
love your nail color he did he was just
so nice and so happy and God you really
got you look really good and you got it
first
what's your ETA 19 minutes Oh wrong mine
is it 3 he's on the street I'm not first
but not last the shoelace is currently
at 219 so all right let's go get yours
baby two minutes away he's on Highland
so we'll see he's making his approach
that's him right there
I feel like my guy is gonna like just
throw the food out at me oh wait I think
it is mine was nicer yeah that's nice he
didn't like compliment me or say
anything about it but all right Joyce is
nowhere to be found but we just got
noticed that our foods here so we're
gonna get it right 12:19 like it said it
would she was waiting at the door that's
true it was like oh we can pick it up
and she literally wasn't gonna give it
to me she was like you're not Joyce foot
points like she's like what's your name
and I go Lindsay like [ __ ] so she was
very protective that Joyce got her food
so now it's just up to quality a little
yeah oh you got a big walk you guys have
I don't have any ketchup yeah
damn it Dave I got my fries fries in the
burger
we both got coke but I got it in this
and then I got a guys what time with
your food put in - put in at 11:38 a.m.
wait - 1141 yet it still came first time
I was 11:30 that's crazy that's so come
on door - did I do better is everything
right now this is my burger I've ever
done you have a bun wait what okay
yeah that was so what so there's a user
area near me we are all germanized let
me see how dishes uncle Gemini how cheap
it was [ __ ]
plus my definitely one that okay how
fast it was oh okay the best service
when the game it was a really nice guy -
oh for - for yeah projector definitely
points I think that's a good time and
then quality you did mates again oh
we're all winners because we all got a
burger acceleration Chileans you gotta
try
[Music]
[Music]